he says no I don't consider myself
married to Mary
like he just made the decision sister
wife star Mary Brown shares a cryptic
message just one day after revealing she
and Cody are over he's like like we're
not married we're not acting as married
and I said to him then if that's where
we are don't you think that we should
address that publicly he said no I don't
want to address it
I don't want to dress it I don't want
that to be out there publicly because I
don't want that judgment well it became
public on Sunday during the Sister Wives
one-on-one special and on Monday the TLC
star posted this selfie alongside some
words of wisdom writing quote if you
don't want to make waves keep on being
mediocre do the thing that everyone else
is doing seek everyone else's opinion
and validation do what everyone else
thinks you should do but on the flip
side Mary adds let them judge you let
them talk about you let them create
their own stories about you find your
courage find your strength know who you
are and don't let them tell you any
different Mary ends her message with
these encouraging words worthy up sister
I've got a good online community that I
work with on a daily basis and you know
there's I keep myself busy but Mary is
not the only former sister wife moving
forward in a positive way we've been
created for several months what
yeah since Janelle and Cody's separation
news earlier this month the mom of six
revealed she's now prioritizing her
health
[Music]
in the caption Janelle writes I'm ready
for you 2023 this health Journey I've
been on has been incredible the results
weren't overnight and I'm okay with that
it's all about slow and steady that wins
the race 2023 is my year I'm finding so
much value and so much richness and
deepness and it increases as for
Christine she's also living her best
life I decided no I really didn't and so
I started moving forward and I just
don't I don't I didn't look back I never
looked back I just started moving
forward the reality star ended her
25-year relationship with Cody last
November I still stand firm believing is
100
the right thing to do and since then
Christine's moved to Utah and found new
happiness
you know everything is a lot more simple
than it used to be which I didn't even
think about but I'm single now right so
I kind of just decide what I want to do
and then do it and it's been just very
very simple like no committed decisions
anymore and everything's just a lot
easier and part of Christine's new
chapter filming Sister Wives in a new
location check out this selfie she
posted filming in her new digs and even
though she's not a sister wife anymore
she told ET in October why she's
sticking with the show I made like a
promise to like Cody and everybody else
and I will stay with Sister Wives as
long as we have the show just to be fair
it's what our family's been doing for so
long and so no I absolutely I feel like
it would be disloyal if I you know
decided to not be part of the show
[Music]